my name is Jay Holly and my superhero
project is about making your program run
faster so nowadays computer systems
especially computation dense one have
more than one CPU cores so people need
to write parallel program in order to
utilize all those cores simultaneously
however the compiler we have today is
not very effective at optimizing these
parallel programs so my project aims to
change that and our primary approach
actually stems from this observation
that there are a lot of optimizations
that our compiler does today that work
perfectly on serial programs but fail to
translate to parallel programs because
of the unfamiliar parallel constructs
that can be found in parallel programs
so in order to address this we actually
do our inspiration from a prior project
called taper so when we have a parallel
program we create a mirror program of it
that does the exact same computation but
we get rid of all the parallel
constructs we call it's the serial
projection of this parallel program we
then run the compiler optimizations on
the serial projection and for each
transformation the optimization does we
mirror it back on to the parallel
program that one we want to optimize so
by doing this in the evaluation that we
have wrong we have been able to observe
of a speed of up to 31 percent
on certain benchmarks so this means the
program would take 31 percent less time
to run so I think with this we have
demonstrated that is indeed possible and
feasible to effectively implement the
optimization for parallel programs in a
compiled